This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。“绝对真人”。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代社会中，培养心理韧性、健身意识以及抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字的2%。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。欢迎收听《回溯往昔》播客。从1979年开始，对当时的我和来说是个重要时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一期，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及我们最喜欢的作家一起。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔在讨论80年代时那样。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. does not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回溯往昔》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《艰难学习》栏目，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·加姆斯。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方进行都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一副铠甲。它向世界传递出一个信号：你是不好惹的。而仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着。并不意味着你必须这么做。
Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Big topic this week, big topic for our 20s as well. We're talking about interpersonal conflict of all sorts on this episode. We're talking about fighting. We're talking about the drama of arguments, of fights with family, of friends.
在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听并学习《艰难学习》。你好，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》，这是一个探讨我们在二十多岁时所经历的一些重大变化与过渡，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。本周的主题很大，对我们二十多岁的人来说这也是个重大主题。这一集我们要讨论各种人际冲突。我们要讨论争吵。我们要讨论争吵的戏剧性，与家人、朋友争吵的戏剧性。
It's pretty normal to have conflict with people as we're figuring ourselves out, but also in general, not just in our 20s. We fight and we start conflict when we're misunderstood, when we feel underappreciated, slighted, betrayed, and for no reason at all, really. I think fights between our friends, our partners, maybe our colleagues, definitely our families. It's a real normal part of daily life, maybe not daily life, but life in general. So today I really want to discuss the psychology behind why we have conflict with people, maybe some more than others, why we can't let things go, why we rehearse arguments in our head, and how to release anger towards another person. Psychology has so much to say about interpersonal conflict.
在摸索自我的过程中，与人产生冲突是相当正常的，而且不仅限于二十多岁，在生活中也是如此。当我们被误解、感到不被欣赏、受到轻视、被背叛，甚至根本毫无理由时，我们就会争吵，就会引发冲突。我认为，朋友、伴侣、同事之间，当然还有家人之间的争吵。这是日常生活，或者说整个人生中一个非常正常的组成部分。所以今天我真的很想探讨为什么我们会与人产生冲突背后的心理学，为什么有些人之间的冲突会比其他人更多，为什么我们总是对事情耿耿于怀，为什么我们在脑海中反复排练争吵，以及如何释放对另一个人的愤怒。心理学对人际冲突有很多见解。
It's a massive part of social psychology. so let's dive right in. I don't think we need a definition of conflict unless you are the most peaceful person in the world. I'm sure we've all had a fight with someone or a disagreement of some kind that went a little bit too far. It's a pretty nasty feeling.
这是社会心理学中极其重要的一部分。让我们马上开始吧。除非你是世界上最爱好和平的人，否则我认为我们不需要对冲突下一个定义。我敢肯定，我们都曾与某人发生过争吵，或者有过某种有点过头的意见不合。那是一种相当糟糕的感觉。
It's an anxious feeling to be fighting with someone close to us, especially when we don't really know how it's going to work out or if things can be fixed. I don't think that fighting with us interpersonal conflict is avoidable, but we can make it easier on ourselves and others and have happy outcomes rather than disastrous ones, I guess. So there are many reasons that conflict in our
与我们亲近的人争吵会有一种焦虑感，尤其是当我们真的不知道事情会如何发展，或者问题能否得到解决的时候。我认为，与我们发生的人际冲突是不可避免的，但我们可以让自己和他人过得更轻松一些，并迎来快乐的结局，而不是灾难性的结局，我想是的。所以，在我们的人际关系中，冲突可能由许多原因引起，
interpersonal relationships may arise, maybe even more common with people we love or who we're close to because we feel comfortable enough to express our anger and our insecurities. We're also more likely to feel misunderstood by the people we believe should understand us. So that perception of feeling misunderstood. Perhaps it's not the reality that they don't understand you. They probably understand you more than most people, but that perception that they should know, they should know how you'd be feeling.
也许与我们爱的人或亲近的人在一起时更为常见，因为我们觉得足够自在，可以表达我们的愤怒和不安全感。我们也更容易觉得那些我们认为应该理解我们的人并不理解我们。因此，就会产生那种觉得被误解的感知。也许现实并非他们不理解你。他们可能比大多数人都更理解你，但那种感知让他们觉得，他们应该知道，他们应该知道你的感受。
They should know how you react to their words, to their actions. So yeah, I think when we have people close to us, it's probably more common that we have that conflict with them. And I think although there's a lot of dialogue around how fighting is healthy for your relationships, which it is and we'll discuss why. It doesn't always lead to the best outcomes in the moment or in the long run. If you're screaming at someone, you're probably not listening to their perspective. If you're really mad, it's very hard to see where they might be coming from.
他们应该知道你对他们的言语、对他们的行动会有什么反应。所以，是的，我认为当我们身边有亲近的人时，与他们发生冲突可能更常见。而且我认为，尽管有很多关于争吵对你的关系有益的讨论——这确实有益，我们稍后也会讨论原因——但在当时或从长远来看，它并不总是能带来最好的结果。如果你在对某人大喊大叫，你大概就没有在听取他们的观点。如果你真的很生气，你就很难看出他们的立场是什么。
And it's hard to express where you're coming from as well. Arguing and fighting can actually lead to worse outcomes because we don't sit back and think about both sides of the narrative. Take this study, for example. So a study of nurses found that when they argued about patient care on the treatment floor, they were less likely to arrive at a good decision and lost focus on the task at hand in favor of the interpersonal conflict. That's a pretty real-world example. You know, they're not able to actually provide care as well if fighting and conflict is getting in the way.
而且也很难表达你自己的立场。争论和争吵实际上可能会导致更糟糕的结果，因为我们不会坐下来思考叙事的双方。以这项研究为例。一项针对护士的研究发现，当她们在治疗室里就患者护理问题发生争论时，她们就不太可能做出正确的决定，并且会把注意力从手头的工作上转移开，转而关注人际冲突。这是一个非常现实的例子。你知道，如果争吵和冲突妨碍了她们，她们就无法真正把护理工作做好。
So where does this kind of nastiness? Not so much nastiness. I don't want to use the word conflict again. these disruptions to the harmony of our relationships. Yeah, where does fighting come from? Why does it occur? Anger at someone can come from quite a few places, obviously. And there's a few main reasons that psychologists have kind of identified
那么，这种讨厌的？也不完全是讨厌。我不想再用“冲突”这个词了。这些对我们关系和谐的破坏。是的，争吵是从哪里来的？为什么会发生？对某人的愤怒显然可以源于很多地方。心理学家已经确定了几个主要原因，
as the leading causes of arguments amongst people. So firstly, and we've already mentioned this, but you feel misunderstood. Misunderstandings are common and they're often innocuous, yet they can create conflict, as I'm sure we're all aware. Perhaps someone has misheard something you've said, and now they're angry with you. Perhaps they heard your words correctly, but comprehended them in a manner that did not align with your intent. Or perhaps they interpreted your silence in a way that was consistent or inconsistent with the message you wanted to send. Importantly, people aren't mind readers. My therapist says this to me all the time.
它们是导致人与人之间争论的主要诱因。首先，我们已经提到过了，你觉得自己被误解了。误解是很常见的，而且通常是无恶意的，但正如我们所知，它们会引发冲突。也许有人听错了你的话，现在他们生你的气了。也许他们听清了你的话，但对它们的理解与你的初衷并不一致。或者，也许他们对你沉默的解读与你想要传递的信息相符或不符。重要的是，人们不会读心术。我的心理学家总是这样对我说。
perception and intention are completely different and our intentions aren't always clear and it's an effort to always have to deliberately signpost exactly what you mean and it's difficult for people to pick up on what we're really saying if we're not being clear so similar to this feeling misunderstood in a more general sense maybe the way someone has treated you or something they've said really contradicts how you see yourself and aspects of your identity that you think are important. So you feel attacked by what you perceive their kind of idea of you as being. You feel misunderstood by how you believe they see you. Regardless of their source, misunderstandings can really damage relationships if they're not handled swiftly. First, you should really ask yourself if you're actually being misunderstood
感知和意图完全是两码事，我们的意图并不总是清晰的，刻意去标明自己到底是什么意思是一件很费劲的事，而且如果我们表达得不够清楚，人们很难察觉到我们真正想说的是什么。所以，类似于这种在更广泛意义上的被误解，也许某人对待你的方式或他们说的话，真正与你的自我认知以及你认为很重要的身份认同方面相矛盾。因此，你会觉得受到了他们对你的那种看法的攻击。你觉得被误解是因为你认为他们是怎么看你的。无论根源是什么，如果不迅速处理，误解确实会损害关系。首先，你真的应该问问自己，你是否真的被误解了，
or if the other person's read of the situation is maybe warranted. I think often we privilege our viewpoints and presume objectivity when, in fact, what we said can indeed be interpreted in so many ways. Even slight changes in tone. Another study that was done that I found really interesting was they gave this script of three lines to the same individuals, to the same script to different individuals, sorry. and they asked them to read out their lines to a partner, not someone they were close to, or just someone they were partnered with for the experiment.
或者另一个人对局势的解读也许是合理的。我认为，通常我们会赋予自己的观点特权，并假定其客观性，而事实上，我们所说的话确实可以有多种不同的解读。甚至连语调的微小变化也能说明问题。另一项让我觉得非常有趣的研究是，他们把三行台词的剧本交给了同一个人，呃，抱歉，是把同一份剧本交给了不同的人。并且他们要求这些人向一个搭档大声朗读他们的台词，这个搭档不是他们熟悉的人，而只是他们在实验中的搭档。
And then afterwards they asked their partner to rate the tone or the attitude of the person or the meaning of what they were saying, their emotion behind what they were saying on a scale. And they gave them different kind of scale. So how happy do you think this person was? Do you think this person was angry? Do you think this person was upset? and there were like so many different interpretations.
事后，他们让搭档给这个人的语调、态度、所说话语的含义，以及他们说话背后的情绪打分。他们给出了各种不同的量表。比如，你觉得这个人有多快乐？你觉得这个人生气了吗？你觉得这个人沮丧吗？结果有各种各样不同的解读。
And I think when that happens, we need to communicate. Tell someone how you felt, but also take on board what they believe their intentions were. Ask them, why did you say that? Why did you think that was appropriate? And let them explain themselves, give them, you know, a platform to maybe actually fix what has started. Like I said, people can't read your mind. So if you're not clear about your reaction to their, actions or words, resentment can start to build. This leads us to the second reason you may find
我想当这种情况发生时，我们需要沟通。告诉别人你的感受，但同时也要听取他们认为自己的意图是什么。问问他们，你为什么这么说？你为什么觉得那样做是合适的？让他们解释一下，给他们一个平台，让他们去实际修复已经发生的矛盾。就像我说的，别人不会读心术。所以，如果你对他们的行为或言语的反应表达得不够清楚，怨恨就会开始积聚。这就引出了你可能会发现自己与所爱之人发生争吵或冲突的第二个原因。
yourself fighting or in conflict with someone you care about. Something has been building for a while. Maybe it's a comment you can't let go of or a pattern of behavior that you haven't called out before believing that the other person will maybe recognize your disappointment themselves someday. This really happens. People aren't going to wake up and be like, oh, I think that person is mad at me and they're probably not going to even know where it started. Instead, if you hold on to every slight and start keeping a mental list of everything they said, everything they've done that they should know is wrong, soon you'll crack and inevitably the outcome will be worse than if you had just said something the moment you recognize you were feeling hurt. The explosion of emotions
有些事情已经积压了一段时间。也许是一句让你无法释怀的评论，或者是某种你以前没有指出来过的不良行为模式，你当时认为对方也许有一天会自己意识到你的失望。这种情况时常发生。人们不会一觉醒来就想：“哦，我觉得那个人生我的气了”，而且他们可能甚至都不知道这一切是从哪里开始的。相反，如果你对每一次轻视都耿耿于怀，开始在脑海中列出一张清单，记下他们说过的一切、做过的一切他们本该知道是错的事，那么很快你就会崩溃，而结果不可避免地会比你一感到受伤就立刻说出来更糟糕。情绪的爆发
that we all probably understand after the fact is never helpful because it's likely you're partner or your friend or your family member doesn't even remember what caused you to be upset in the first place. They can't remember that comment they made. They can't remember that time, you know, you looked away or you rolled your eyes and they'll feel attacked and immediately on the defensive. And we're going to discuss why people react this way to confrontation in a few minutes. But finally, the last reason that psychologists have found we fight for, you feel hurt by someone's actions. This is probably the most obvious reason. Maybe they have done something deliberately and you feel betrayed or lied to and hurt. And that's completely valid. Sometimes fighting in these
事后我们可能都能理解，但这种爆发是毫无帮助的，因为你的伴侣、朋友或家人很可能根本不记得最初是什么让你生气的。他们记不得他们说过的那句评论。他们记不得你当时，你知道的，把视线移开或者翻白眼的那一刻，他们会觉得自己受到了攻击，并立即处于防御状态。几分钟后我们将讨论为什么人们对对抗会有这种反应。不过最后，心理学家发现我们争吵的最后一个原因是，你觉得自己的行为受到了伤害。这可能是最明显的原因。也许他们做了一些故意的举动，让你觉得自己被背叛了、被欺骗了，受到了伤害。这是完全合理的。有时候在这些情况下争吵
situations can be useful, especially in romantic relationships. Obviously, it has its limits. We're not talking about resorting to physical violence. But expressing your emotions right away is probably a good practice to have rather than waiting for that volcanic eruption of anger and resentment and attacks. Heaps of studies have found that fighting with a partner, a boyfriend or a girlfriend, might actually be quite healthy. I always remember this one scene from the office. I don't know why. It's really stuck with me, but if you are in office, an office connoisseur, like myself, if you've watched it a few times, or maybe just once, you'll know Jim and Pam. even if you haven't watched the office, Jim and Pam, the couple, you know, the star couple of the show.
会很有用，特别是在恋爱关系中。当然，这也有它的限度。我们不是在谈论诉诸身体暴力。但即时表达你的情绪可能是一个好习惯，而不是等待火山爆发般的愤怒、怨恨和攻击。大量研究发现，与伴侣——男朋友或女朋友争吵，实际上可能相当健康。我总是想起《办公室》里的这个场景。我不知道为什么。它深深地留在了我的脑海里，但如果你是《办公室》的行家，像我一样，如果你看过好几次，或者哪怕只看过一次，你就会认识吉姆和帕姆。即使你没看过《办公室》，吉姆和帕姆这对情侣，你知道的，剧中的明星情侣。
And after they've been married for a couple of years, they start to have this sense of misunderstanding that their needs aren't being met. And Jim, they're at this kind of climax of this, you know, they're almost at the point where they just need to fight. And they, Jim says to Pam, you know, I don't want to go home because if we go home, we're just going to fight. And Pam says, I want to fight. I really want to. And that's kind of a really healthy way of seeing it. She's not avoiding it another minute longer. She's not saying, oh, this can wait because it can't.
在他们结婚几年后，他们开始产生一种误解，觉得自己的需求没有得到满足。而吉姆，他们正处于这种状况的某种高潮，你知道的，他们几乎到了只需要打一架的地步。然后吉姆对帕姆说，你知道的，我不想回家，因为如果我们回家，我们只会吵架。帕姆说，我想吵架。我真的很想。这其实是一种非常健康的看待方式。她没有再多逃避哪怕一分钟。她没有说，“哦，这可以等，因为这不能等”。
And she knows that if things build up, I guess it's just going to lead to worse outcomes. So she says, I want to have that argument. Couple goals, honestly. And when you fight with someone, I think the reason it's healthy is because it shows that you both care. If you didn't, you wouldn't be concerned with feeling like your perspective had to be understood or that you needed the conflict to resolve. When I guess partners fight within an environment that allows clear expression, this can help strengthen their bond.
她知道如果事情积聚起来，我想这只会导致更糟糕的结果。所以她说，我想进行那场争论。老实说，这就是情侣模范。当你和某人吵架时，我认为它之所以健康，是因为它表明你们都在乎对方。如果你不在乎，你就不会关心自己的观点是否被理解，或者你是否需要解决冲突。我想当伴侣们在一个允许清晰表达的环境中争吵时，这有助于巩固他们的纽带。
With partners both kind of actively participating to resolve the disagreement, there's comfort as well, a learned comfort, in knowing that conflicts can be maturely and warmly handled without risking the relationship's future. it's kind of a really good way to avoid anxiety around upsetting someone or avoid anxiety around you know are they mad at me if you get into that practice of just speaking your mind early and i think with this partners can freely bring up disappointments and unhappiness without leaving room for resentment ultimately this can kind of help to strengthen the relationship and probably improve its odds of
当伴侣双方都在积极参与解决分歧时，也会有一种安慰，一种习得的安慰，即知道冲突可以在成熟和温暖的情况下处理，而不会危及这段关系未来。这算是一种非常好的方法，可以避免因惹恼别人而产生焦虑，或者避免因“他们是不是在生我的气”而产生焦虑。如果你养成了早早说出自己想法的习惯，我想伴侣就可以自由地提出失望和不愉快，而不会留下滋生怨恨的空间。归根结底，这有助于巩固这段关系，并可能提高它持久的几率。
lasting. I would say so. I don't know any couple who would have lasted a long time who wouldn't have had an argument. It's like once you get over that first few arguments, you know, it makes you a lot stronger. And you learn more about the other person because I think somewhere in the process of listing out your grievances and offering your partner's clarification in uncertain areas or accepting your partner's clarification, you both learn new things about each other. You learn what upsets them. you learn what maybe triggers them, what behaviors they don't like, how you can treat them better. It might also be things like communication methods. So maybe your partner's voice goes lower when they are feeling particularly hurt.
我觉得是这样的。我不知道有哪对能维持很久的情侣是没有吵过架的。这就好比一旦你度过了最初的几次争吵，你知道的，它会让你变得坚强得多。而且你会更多地了解另一个人，因为我认为在罗列你的委屈、为伴侣在不确定领域提供的澄清做解释、或是接受伴侣澄清的某个过程中，你们双方都会对彼此有新的了解。你会了解是什么让他们心烦意乱。你会了解是什么可能会触发他们的情绪，他们不喜欢什么行为，你如何能更好地对待他们。这也可能是沟通方式之类的事情。所以也许你的伴侣在感到特别受伤时声音会变低。
And that's something you can pick up on in the future. And it could also be knowing that certain practices like tuddling before bed and non-negotiable for their happiness because if they're bringing it up with you, they know what's best for them and they know what they like and what they don't like and what makes them happy. and other times it may simply be learning about their hopes for the relationship but also your fears like if you're worried about fighting are you fearful that you know your partner might leave you are you fearful that something's wrong so so far those kind of ones we just talked about we've been talking about conflict or fights that seem to have a purpose or which are trying to get us to a place of deeper understanding and i know i used intimate relationships or like, you know, partners as an example, but that can also apply to friends as well and to family, getting to, you know, having the opportunity to strengthen your bond and understand what's okay and what's not in your relationship. But what about the times when we really don't need to be arguing? Why do we start fights when we don't want to have a fight, when we don't want to argue?
这是你以后可以注意到的事情。这也可能意味着知道某些习惯，比如睡前依偎在一起，对他们的幸福来说是不可妥协的，因为如果他们把它提出来，他们就知道什么对他们最好，他们知道自己喜欢什么、不喜欢什么、什么能让他们快乐。而有时，这可能只是了解他们对这段关系的期望，以及你的恐惧，比如如果你担心吵架，你是否担心你的伴侣可能会离开你，你是否担心有什么不对劲。所以到目前为止，我们刚才谈到的那些，我们一直在讨论那些似乎有目的的冲突或争吵，或者是那些试图把我们带到一个更深层次理解境地的冲突或争吵，我知道我用亲密关系或伴侣作为例子，但这也可以应用到朋友和家人身上，去获得，你知道的，获得巩固你们的纽带、理解在你们的关系中什么可以接受、什么不可以的机会。但是那些我们真的不需要争吵的时候呢？当我们不想吵架、不想争论时，为什么我们要挑起争端？
Sometimes we can get into these argument cycles, especially with intimate partners. And this is something that social psychology has seen a lot. when we look at married couples or we look at partners who are in long distance or long-term relationships. So this happens when we're arguing about the same thing over and over again, even when we don't want to, even when we feel like previously we've come to a good conclusion. So these argument cycles are usually caused by negative communication patterns that restrict understanding and respect in a relationship or that kind of force that understanding to only be in the short term. You know, maybe you're just accepting that person's viewpoint just to finish the argument.
有时候我们会陷入这些争吵的循环中，特别是与亲密伴侣在一起时。这是社会心理学中经常看到的一种现象。当我们审视已婚夫妇或处于异地恋或长期关系中的伴侣时。所以，当我们一次又一次地为同一件事情争吵时，即使我们并不想这样，即使我们觉得以前已经得到了一个好的结论，这种情况就会发生。因此，这些争吵的循环通常是由消极的沟通模式引起的，这些模式限制了关系中的理解和尊重，或者迫使这种理解只能维持在短期内。你知道的，也许你只是为了结束争论而接受了对方的观点。
And you never actually do reach a good understanding of where they're coming from on a deeper level. It's not really the topic of the argument that matters. It's what the need to argue represents. And that might be poor communication. It might be unresolved problems, but it might also just be that you didn't listen the first time. Apart from argument cycles, which if you're interested in you should Google, or if you're finding yourself in that situation, it's completely normal and it's, yeah, there's a lot of interesting research behind it. So if you're interested, have a Google. But there are other reasons we may argue just for the sake of it. So if you've followed the science of sleep at all, you know that missing sleep has all kinds of negative
而你从来没有真正对他们深层次的立场达成一个良好的理解。重要的其实不是争论的话题，而是争论的需求所代表的东西。那可能是糟糕的沟通。那可能是未解决的问题，但也有可能只是你第一次没有听进去。除了争吵的循环——如果你感兴趣的话应该去谷歌一下，或者如果你发现自己正处于这种状况中，这是完全正常的，而且，是的，其背后有许多有趣的研究。所以如果你感兴趣，可以去谷歌一下。但我们为了争吵而争吵还有其他原因。所以，如果你对睡眠科学有所了解，你就会知道缺少睡眠会有各种各样的负面
effects. I'm such a proponent of this. Everyone knows if you don't get enough sleep, if you don't get those seven, eight hours, what are you doing? Go back to bed. How a nap? and sick. It's bad for your health, your brain and your ability to get things done. And I think sleep also plays an important role in arguments as well, even when you kind of weed out the effects of related issues like stress and anxiety. And a study that looked at couples in a laboratory found that even when just one partner had gotten too little sleep, both partners were less likely to act warmly towards one another or resolve problems and more likely to get into fights. And it's this idea of like a self-fulfilling prophecy or reciprocation effect, which we've talked
影响。我是这方面的坚定支持者。每个人都知道，如果你睡眠不足，如果你没有睡够那七八个小时，你在干嘛？回床上睡觉去。去小睡一下。而且生病。这对你的健康、大脑和完成任务的能力都不好。而且我认为睡眠在争论中也扮演着重要的角色，即使你排除了压力和焦虑等相关问题的影响。一项在实验室中对伴侣进行的研究发现，即使只有一个伴侣睡眠不足，双方对彼此表现出热情或解决问题的可能性也会降低，而发生争吵的可能性则会增加。这就是所谓的“自证预言”或“互惠效应”，我们已经讨论过好几次了。
about a few times. So the reciprocity, I can never pronounce it. Reciprocity, yeah, the reciprocity. I don't know why I keep saying it, but that effect, where if someone is treating you warmly, you'll respond warmly. And if someone is cranky and in a bad mood, you'll probably respond in the same way. Conflict may also arise because you're irritated or you're projecting on someone close to you. So Freud's idea of projection is super important when we consider interpersonal conflict, especially amongst people close to us. Projection, it occurs when we place our unwanted emotions and feelings onto someone else who is not the intended target. We displace our feelings onto them because we may be frustrated at someone else or another situation,
所以互惠，我总是发不好这个音。互惠，是的，互惠。我不知道为什么我一直说这个词，但那种效应就是，如果别人热情地对待你，你也会热情地回应。而如果某人脾气暴躁、心情不好，你很可能也会以同样的方式回应。冲突的产生也可能是因为你感到烦躁，或者你在把情绪投射到与你亲密的人身上。因此，当我们考虑人际冲突时，尤其是当我们考虑与我们亲密的人之间的冲突时，弗洛伊德的投射概念超级重要。投射，它发生在我们将自己不想要的感情和情绪强加给并非预期目标的人身上。我们将自己的情绪转移到他们身上，因为我们可能对其他人或另一种情况感到沮丧，
but feel like we can't really voice our anger or frustration to the person or to the situation who really deserves it. And I had this happen to me the other day. I was really frustrated at this person I was seeing. I can't remember why. It's probably reasonable though. And I was in a bad mood. And my sister asked me to drive her somewhere and I didn't want to because I was irritated.
但又觉得无法向真正该承担责任的人或情况表达我们的愤怒或挫败感。我前几天就遇到了这种情况。我对那个我正在交往的人感到非常沮丧。我不记得为什么了。不过可能也是有原因的。而且我当时心情很不好。我姐姐让我开车送她去一个地方，我不想去，因为我很烦躁。
And she pushed it and I just got really upset. and we ended up having like a bit of a screaming match. We had a bit of an argument. But the thing is, I wasn't mad at her. Like, I wasn't upset. She just wanted to drive to office works. I was mad at that other person but couldn't express it to them. So I found a new target, someone close to me.
她一直催促我，我一下子就非常心烦意乱。我们最后甚至有点像是在大喊大叫。我们吵了一架。但问题是，我不是在生她的气。真的，我并不心烦。她只是想开车去办公用品店。我在生另一个人的气，却无法对他们发泄。所以我找到了一个新的目标，一个离我很近的人。
And projection could be the reason why you keep snapping at people who you really don't have the main problem with. And it can leave you feeling really guilty. You know, maybe it's like a close friend or your housemate. You're just in such a rotten mood. You've had a bad day at work, and they're the ones who kind of cop the sharp end of it. We're going to talk about what to do in those situations. What you shouldn't do in a fight if you want to have a healthy and happy conclusion.
而投射可能就是你总是对那些你实际上并没有主要问题的人发脾气的原因。这会让你感到非常内疚。你知道的，也许就像一个亲密的朋友或你的室友。你当时心情糟透了。你度过了糟糕的一天，而他们却成了承受这一切恶果的人。我们将讨论在这些情况下该怎么做。如果你想有一个健康和快乐的结局，你在争吵时不应该做什么。
So you and someone are fighting. What shouldn't you do? That's a really big question, I think people ask the therapist or other people. A lot. What shouldn't you do? What's not effective? And the first thing is criticism. You really shouldn't criticize someone when you're arguing with them.
所以你和某人在吵架。你不应该做什么？我认为这是一个人们经常问治疗师或其他人的大问题。有很多。你不做什么？什么是没有成效的？第一件事就是批评。你在和别人争论时，真的不应该批评对方。
Criticism happens when you're critical of your partner's personality rather than the action or behavior you're trying to talk through. And there's a distinction between a criticism and a complaint. They argue that expressing a complaint today being this person that I was reading this from. So this author argues that expressing a complaint is an important component of a healthy relationship and it reduces the likely of built up. anger, which we've talked about. Expressing a criticism, however, involves making an accusation against the person's personality. A complaint often starts with I, whereas a criticism starts with you. So, for example, a complaint might be, I'd love to eat, I don't want to eat leftovers
当你批评伴侣的人格，而不是试图沟通的行动或行为时，批评就发生了。批评和抱怨是有区别的。他们认为，表达抱怨是健康关系的一个重要组成部分，它能减少积压的可能性，
for dinner every week, whereas a criticism might be you always order too much food. Contempt commonly follows criticism, and it's problematic because it can be poisonous to any kind of relationship you have. So we want to keep contempt out of our fights. So contempt according to this Gottman model, which is really interesting if you want to Google it, is statements made with the intention of insulting or psychologically wounding your partner. So common ways in which contempt is often expressed in a relationship is through sarcastic remarks, antagonistic commentary, mocking behavior or hostility. And it's such a strong emotion, but you would be surprised how often it's used against others and used against your otherwise well-meaning partner.
批评通常伴随着对个人人格的指责。抱怨通常以“我”开头，而批评则以“你”开头。例如，抱怨可能是：我很想吃东西，我不想每天晚上都吃剩饭。而批评则可能是：你总是点太多外卖。蔑视通常紧随批评之后，它之所以是个问题，是因为它对你所拥有的任何关系都具有毒害性。所以我们要把蔑视排除在争吵之外。因此，根据这个戈特曼模型——如果你想在谷歌上搜索它，它非常有趣——蔑视是指带有侮辱或心理伤害伴侣意图的言论。在关系中表达蔑视的常见方式通常是通过讽刺的言语、敌对的评论、嘲弄的行为或敌意。这是一种如此强烈的情感，但你可能会惊讶于它被用来攻击他人以及对你原本出于好意的伴侣的频率有多高。
Contempts hurt, contempt hurts the person you're arguing with. And it hurts your relationship, so it's good to keep it out. I think couples are often so focused on feeling defensive that it can become an instinctual reaction. So this Gottman model, it's said, to kind of try to not feel defensive. Try and just get your point across, but accept what the other person is saying. It doesn't matter what was said or what was intended when they said it. The other person feels hurt and reacts defensively.
蔑视会带来伤害，蔑视会伤害你正在争论的人。它会损害你们的关系，所以最好把它排除在外。我认为伴侣们常常过于专注于感到防御，以至于这成了一种本能反应。所以这个戈特曼模型，据说，是尽量不要让自己感到防备。试着把你的观点表达清楚，但要接受对方所说的话。无论说了什么，或者他们在说这话时意图是什么并不重要。对方感到了伤害，并作出了防备的反应。
So effectively defensive reactions means you're like pre-guessing, you're not listening. You're just looking for a way to defend yourself. And it's not going to make you very good at solving real problems in real time. The other thing you really shouldn't do, and this fucking annoys me so much. Stonewalling. Stonewalling happens in a relationship when one or both people in the relationship, and I'm not just talking about romantic. It could be with a friend, with a housemate, with a family member, but it happens when one party stops reacting or
因此，有效的防备反应意味着你在瞎猜，你没有在听。你只是在寻找保护自己的方法。这并不能让你很好地实时解决真正的问题。你真的不应该做的另一件事，这他妈的太让我烦了。冷暴力。冷暴力发生在恋爱关系中，当关系中的一方或双方——我指的不仅仅是浪漫关系。它可能发生在朋友、室友、家庭成员之间，但它发生在一方停止对另一方做出反应或回应的时候。
responding to the other. And this occurs most often after all the other communication patterns, criticism, contempt and defensiveness, have been a standard part of your relationship for some time. So likely you're feeling overwhelmed by the problems in your relationship with the other person, so you just withdraw emotionally from each other. stonewalling is an active gesture in that it clearly intends to convey a lack of care or interest and we talked about this fighting is good it shows you still interested so if you're stonewalling someone it shows to them that you don't really give a damn and it's an indication that your relationship is probably becoming a little bit unstuck if you're not even willing to talk about it let the other person
这种情况最常发生在你关系中的所有其他沟通模式——批评、蔑视和防御——已经成为常态一段时间之后。所以很可能是你对你们关系中的问题或对方感到不知所措，所以你们在情感上彼此疏离了。冷暴力是一种积极的姿态，因为它清楚地意图传达一种缺乏关心或兴趣的信息。我们之前讨论过，争吵是好的，它表明你仍然感兴趣。所以如果你对某人冷暴力，这就向他们表明你根本不在乎，如果你们甚至不愿意谈论它，让另一方
speak take time away from the argument and that's the other big one i saw this tic-tok um about the couple and when they argue they have this like timeout symbol what's just the timeout symbol and it means that they need to break and they should go on a walk or do something that they like doing together and i thought that was um so smart i was like wow i wish i could do that with someone like i'm having an argument with my mom and i'm like oh my god mom time out i wish that was something we could do which we probably could it's a really really healthy strategy there are some people though who seem to always be having conflict, maybe with you or with others. Maybe you have a friend who seems to always have some grievance with your mutual friends or is arguing with their partner week in and week out. And although
说话，从争论中抽身出来，这表明你们的关系可能已经有点破裂了，这是我看到的关于情侣的另一个重大话题，当他们争吵时，他们有这样一个暂停手势，就是简单的暂停手势，这意味着他们需要休息，他们应该去散步或做他们喜欢一起做的事，我觉得这太聪明了，我想，哇，我希望我也能和某人这样做，就像我和我妈妈吵架时，我就会说，哦，天哪，妈妈，暂停，我希望那是我们可以做到的事，虽然我们大概也能做到，这真的是一个非常非常健康的策略。不过有些人似乎总是与人冲突，也许是和你，也许是和别人。也许你有一个朋友，似乎总是对你们共同的朋友有什么委屈，或者周复一周地和他们的伴侣争吵。虽然
the latter sounds like more of a problematic relationship than anything else, these kinds of people are known as high conflict individuals. People who have a pattern of high conflict behavior that increases fighting in arguments with others rather than reducing or resolving conflict. This pattern usually happens over and over again in many different situations with many different people. It's not just that when they're cranky and tired, they start conflict or it's just with their boyfriend. It's kind of a universal pattern. And the issue that seems in conflict at the time, it's not what's increasing the conflict. This person could argue about anything. The real issue is the high conflict personality and how the person approaches problem solving. So with these high
后者听起来更像是一个问题重重的关系，但这类人被称为高冲突个体。这样的人有一种高冲突行为模式，会增加与他人争吵的机会，而不是减少或解决冲突。这种模式通常在许多不同的情况下与许多不同的许多人身上一次又一次地发生。不仅是在他们脾气暴躁和疲惫时才挑起冲突，或者只针对他们的男友。这是一种普遍的模式。而且当时似乎处于冲突中的问题，并不是增加冲突的原因。这个人可以为任何事情争论。真正的问题在于高冲突的人格以及这个人处理问题的方式。所以对于这些高冲突个体来说，
conflict individuals, the pattern of behavior might include blaming others, all-or-nothing thinking, unmanaged emotions, extreme behaviours, stonewalling. And it can be really hard to maintain relationships with these people. As your friends, as people in your lives, we don't like being in conflict. We don't like being threatened. And in general, people tend to want to avoid a confrontation. So if you've got someone who seems to almost get joy out of it or seems to make it a ritual, you're not going to want to be around them very often, yelling at someone, fighting with someone,
行为模式可能包括指责他人、非黑即白的思维、失控的情绪、极端行为、冷暴力。与这些人维持关系可能会非常困难。作为你的朋友，作为你生活中的人，我们不喜欢冲突。我们不喜欢被威胁。总的来说，人们往往倾向于想要避免对抗。所以如果你身边有一个人似乎从中获得乐趣或将其视为一种仪式，你一定不会愿意经常和他们在一起，对某人大喊大叫，与某人争吵，
expressing anger immediately places someone on the defensive, which we already kind of mentioned. And this is important to understand on a deeper level from a psychological perspective because it leads to worse outcomes interpersonally. So how does our brain react when we feel threatened? When we perceive a threat, the amygdala, which is an area of the old brain deep in the limbic system, it's responsible for fear and fear responses, the amygdala sounds an alarm, releasing a cascade of chemicals in the body. Stress hormones like adrenaline and cortisol, they flood our system immediately preparing
表达愤怒会立即把人置于防备状态，我们之前已经提到过这一点。从心理学角度更深层次地理解这一点很重要，因为它会导致更糟糕的人际结果。那么当我们感到受到威胁时，我们的大脑是如何反应的呢？当我们感知到威胁时，杏仁核——这是边缘系统深处旧大脑的一个区域，负责恐惧和恐惧反应——杏仁核会拉响警报，在体内释放一连串化学物质。肾上腺素和皮质醇等应激激素会瞬间充斥我们的系统，让我们做好战斗或逃跑的准备。因此，当这种深深的本能功能接管一切时，我们称之为丹尼尔·戈尔曼所创造的词：杏仁核劫持。所以杏仁核的行为几乎立即切断了通往我们前额叶皮层的神经通路。前额叶皮层是我们做决策的地方。因此，我们在激烈的讨论中会迷失方向。而且就像我说的，复杂的决策能力消失了，我们获取多种视角的途径也消失了。同样，我们的额叶也负责同理心，也就是能够设身处地为他人着想。随着我们的
us to fight or to flee. So when this deeply instinctive function takes over, we call it what Daniel Coleman coined as amygdala hijack. So the act of amygdala almost immediately shuts down the neural pathway to our prefrontal cortex. Prefrontal cortex is where we make decisions and we probably themselves. So we become disorientated in a heated discussion. And like I said, complex decision-making disappears, as does our access to multiple perspectives. As that's kind of a way, our frontal lobe is also responsible for empathy, so being able to kind of step into someone else's shoes. So as our
注意力变窄，我们会发现自己陷入了一种让我们觉得最安全的视角中。你知道的，我是对的，你是错的，尽管我们平时本来能够看到对方的立场。如果这还不够，我们的记忆也会变得不可信，因为这个旧大脑关闭了所有的辅助功能，它只专注于当下的事情，即当下的威胁。所以你有没有和伴侣、朋友吵过架？或者和伴侣吵过架？你 literalmente 记不起他们身上哪怕一个积极的地方。
attention narrows, we find ourselves trapped in one perspective that makes us feel the most safe. You know, I'm right and you're wrong, even though we ordinarily would be able to see the other person's side. And if that wasn't enough, our memory becomes untrustworthy as well, because this old brain, it shuts down all of the kind of accessory functions, it just focuses on the thing that's happening in the moment, the threat in the moment. So have you ever been in a partner with a friend or been in a fight with a partner or your friend? And you literally cannot remember a single positive thing about them. you're in this fire and you're like oh my god i fucking hate this person it's as though our brain drops the memory function altogether in an effort to survive the immediate threat and when our memory is compromised like this we can't recall something from the past that might actually help
你身处这场大火中，心里想：哦，天哪，我他妈太讨厌这个人了。就好像为了在即时的威胁中生存下来，我们的大脑完全放弃了记忆功能。而当我们的记忆力像这样受损时，我们就无法回忆起过去可能真正有助于我们冷静下来的事情，事实上，我们几乎记不起任何事情，甚至可能记不起我们是怎么走到这一步的。相反，我们心中充斥着杏仁核那闪烁的红灯，暗示着危险、危险、保护、攻击、反应。在杏仁核劫持的痛苦中，由于神经系统（更具体地说是边缘系统）中那些本能的保护机制，我们无法选择自己想要如何反应。所以这算是对我们为什么不喜欢对抗的一种解释。但我们的大脑确实有一种为之做准备的方式。所以你有没有发现自己在脑海中反复排练争吵？我确信你一定有过。
us calm down in fact we can't really remember much of anything perhaps even how we even got there Instead we're simply filled with this flashing red light of the amygdala indicating danger, danger protect, attack, react. And in the throes of amygdala hijack, we can't choose how we want to react because of those instinctual protective mechanisms in the nervous system, or more specifically the limbic system. So that's kind of an explanation as to why we don't like confrontation. But there's a way that our brain kind of prepares us for it. So have you ever found yourself rehearsing arguments in your head? I'm sure that you have.
幻想你会对别人说什么来真正触动他们，你会对别人说什么来赢得争论或震惊他们。我们的头脑之所以会这样，以及为什么躺在床上或坐在淋浴间里排练假设情况或在脑海中演练冲突会让人觉得如此满足，而现实中这些情况其实压力很大，这是有原因的。通过排练对话，我们是在试图满足我们的需求。如果我们不擅长自信的沟通，有时候提前排练这些对话可以成为在面对艰难交谈时变得更自信的一种方法。它还可以提供一种宣泄，而不需要我们真正去吵架。所以有时候在脑海中排练争论会转移我们对真正痛苦源头的注意力，你知道的，比如我的关系要结束了吗？
Fantasizing about what you would say to someone to really get to them, what you would say to someone to win the argument or to shock them. There is a reason why our minds do this and why it can feel so satisfying to lie in bed or sit in the shower and rehearse hypotheticals or play conflict out in our minds when in reality those situations would be quite stressful. So by rehearsing conversations, we're trying to get our needs net. If we're not good at assertive communication, sometimes rehearsing those conversations in advance can be a way of becoming more confident when difficult chats kind of approach. It can also provide a release without requiring us to actually have the argument. So sometimes rehearsing the arguments in our head distracts us from the real source of distress, you know, like is my relationship going to end?
但它也提供了一个出口，让我们释放一些可能积聚的紧张感。所以这是一种回避另一个问题或明显问题的方式，转而关注手头争论的微小细节，并逃避更大的图景及其影响，从而不仅给大脑以练习，而且在风暴真正来临之前给我们一种释放感。总之，我觉得这真的很有趣，对于那些发现自己在淋浴间和车里排练或想象假想争论的人来说，这是一个小小的趣闻。
But it also provides an outlet so that we kind of release some of the tension that might be building up. So it's kind of a way of avoiding the other problem or the obvious problem. And instead focusing on the minute details of the argument at hand and evading the bigger picture and its implications to give our brain not only practice, but a sense of release before the actual storm. Anyway, I thought that was really interesting, a small tidbit for those who find themselves rehearsing or imagining hypothetical arguments in the shower and the car.
但这也提供了一个宣泄口，让我们得以释放积聚的一些紧张情绪。所以这有点像是避免另一个问题或显而易见的问题的一种方式，转而关注手头争论的微小细节，逃避大局及其影响，在真正的风暴来临之前，不仅给大脑提供练习，还带来一种释放感。总之，我觉得这真的很有趣，对于那些发现自己在淋浴时和车里排练或想象假设性争论的人来说，这是一个小小的趣闻。
I do that all the time. It's like kind of fun. It makes sense from a psychological perspective. My brain kind of gets off on it because it's like a little treat without having to do the real thing. But we do. We start fights for so many reasons and it's so important not to fester. Take time to calm down and tap into what we're genuinely upset about before projecting and fighting that aftermath of guilt, shame and anxiety that might accompany a conflict,
我经常这么做。这其实挺有意思的。从心理学的角度来看，这是说得通的。我的大脑对此有点上瘾，因为它就像是一个小小的奖励，而不需要去做真正的行动。但我们的确会因为很多原因挑起争端，而且重要的是不要让负面情绪发酵。在投射情绪并为此后的内疚、羞耻和焦虑（这些情绪可能会伴随冲突而来）而战之前，花点时间冷静下来，弄清楚我们真正心烦意乱的是什么，
perhaps even one we didn't even want to have in the first place. We've all been there, I've been there, you've been there. But changing from a defensive to a receptive state, like we've talked about, can really be helpful in minimizing the conflict we have with others. Obviously, I'm not a trained psychologist. I'm just kind of researching this stuff, but definitely a lot of these things I do. bring into my own life next time I find myself, you know, arguing with someone or not, I don't really find myself in fights and I find that I'm not very confrontational, but someone was upset at me.
也许甚至是那种我们一开始根本就不想经历的争吵。我们都经历过，我经历过，你也经历过。但是，正如我们所讨论的，从防备状态转变为接受状态，确实有助于减少我们与他人之间的冲突。显然，我不是受过专业训练的心理学家。我只是在研究这些东西，但毫无疑问，这些事情中的很多，我确实会带到我自己的生活中，下次当我发现自己，你知道的，和别人争吵时，或者其实我并不觉得自己经常卷入争吵，我觉得自己不是很喜欢对抗，但当有人对我感到不满时。
I feel like instead of getting defensive, a lot of these strategies would be really useful. Like that timeout strategy, I'm going to, I'm going to do that. Thank you TikTok for showing me the way. Anyhow, I hope you guys learned something about why we fight, why we have arguments, the people in our lives who have arguments more than others. and how to kind of release that anger and get to a better outcome, especially with someone you might be dating or in a long-term relationship with. You don't really want to lose that person.
我觉得与其进行防御，很多这样的策略其实会非常有用。比如那个暂停策略，我打算，我打算去试试。谢谢TikTok为我指明方向。无论如何，我希望你们能学到一些东西：为什么我们会争吵，为什么我们会产生争端，为什么我们生活中的某些人比其他人更容易发生争论，以及如何释放那种愤怒并获得更好的结果，特别是对于你可能正在约会或处于长期关系中的人。你其实并不想失去那个人。
You've invested time and energy and love for a reason. So I hope you enjoyed this episode, and you got something out of it if you've listened all this way. I always say this at the end, but if you do feel called, or if you've liked this episode and you feel called to leave a review, I would greatly appreciate it. you can leave a review on Spotify or Apple Podcasts, and it helps the community of listeners grow, helps people find this episode or other episodes that might be interesting to them. If you don't want to do it, that's fine. Thanks for listening. Thanks for tagging along.
你投入了时间、精力和爱是有原因的。所以我希望你喜欢这一期节目，如果你一直听到这里，能从中有所收获。我总是在最后这么说，但如果你确实有感触，或者如果你喜欢这期节目并有心留下评论，我将不胜感激。你可以在Spotify或Apple Podcasts上留评，这有助于听众社区的成长，帮助人们找到这期节目或他们可能感兴趣的其他节目。如果你不想这么做，也没关系。谢谢收听。谢谢一路陪伴。
And I will see you guys next week, or maybe even in a few days, when we record our Valentine's Day edition of Loveline. Thank you so much, and have a lovely evening, morning, afternoon. wherever you are in the world. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我们下周见，或者甚至几天后见，当我们录制情人节特别版的情感热线时。非常感谢，祝大家有个美好的夜晚、早晨或下午，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。我在这里剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇特的现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast.
成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字2%。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。
In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians,
在1979年，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员，
and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
以及最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那确实是个疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
你正在收听由你喜爱的治疗师兼主持人科尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方进行都真的不够安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的执照专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。这是一个iHeart播客。保证由真人制作。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。